[gangster rap music]
♪♪
>> ♪ KRISPY KREME
♪ AND DANIEL TOSH
♪ DIAMOND STYLE PRODUCTIONS
♪ AND THIS IS A SONG
♪ FOR THE TELEVISION
♪ CHILLIN' IN THE KITCHEN ♪
♪ EATIN' PEANUT BUTTER JELLY ♪
♪ WHEN MY HOMEBOY DANIEL TOSH
♪ CALLED ME ON THE CELLIE
♪ HE SAID "HEY, KRISPY
♪ "YOU'RE COMING OUT TO CALI ♪
♪ "I GOT SOME CUTE GIRLS
♪ AND THERE'S ONE NAMED SALLY" ♪
♪ I GOT UP ON THE AIRPLANE
♪ AND HEADED FOR THE AIRPORT
♪ I SAID, "DANIEL TOSH
♪ "YOU KNOW WHAT I'M THERE FOR ♪
♪ "I'M THERE FOR ALL THE WOMEN ♪
♪ AND THE FAME"
♪ THEN DANIEL TOSH SAID
♪ "I'M THERE ♪
♪ FOR THE SAME THING"
♪ IT'S ME AND DANIEL TOSH ♪
♪ AND WE'RE CHILLIN' IN L.A. ♪
♪ DOING PUSH-UPS
♪ AND GETTING GIRLS ALL DAY
♪ YEAH, WE'RE NEVER EVER ♪
♪ GOING BACK HOME
♪ 'CAUSE NOW ♪
♪ WE'RE BEST FRIENDS ♪
♪ AND WE'LL NEVER BE ALONE ♪
♪ I SAID IT'S ME ♪
♪ AND DANIEL TOSH
♪ AND WE'RE CHILLIN' IN L.A. ♪
♪ DOING PUSH-UPS
♪ AND GETTING GIRLS ALL DAY
♪ AND WE'RE NEVER EVER ♪
♪ GOING BACK HOME
♪ 'CAUSE NOW ♪
♪ WE'RE BEST FRIENDS ♪
♪ AND WE'LL NEVER BE ALONE ♪
♪ BREAK IT DOWN
♪
♪ DANIEL TOSH, BREAK IT DOWN
♪ AND, KRISPY KREME
♪ BREAK IT DOWN
♪
♪ YEAH, JUST BREAK IT DOWN
♪ UHN!
♪
♪ GOT UP IN THE PARTY
♪ THERE WERE GIRLS EVERYWHERE
♪ THEY ASKED IF
♪THEY COULD KISS ME ♪
♪ I SAID "SURE
♪I DON'T CARE" ♪
♪ BUT THEN I LOOKED OVER
♪ AND MY HOMEY'S ALL ALONE ♪
♪ I WALKED OVER TO DANIEL
♪ AND SAID
♪ "WHAT'S THE MATTER, BRO?" ♪
♪ HE SAID "DANG, KRISPY
♪ "I'M JUST NOT VERY SMOOTH ♪
♪ "BUT MAYBE SOMEDAY
♪ "I COULD TOUCH
♪ A GIRL'S BOOBS" ♪
♪ I SAID "YOU AND YOU
♪ "GET OVER HERE
♪ AND HOLD HIS HAND"
♪ THEN DANIEL TOSH SAID
♪ "THANKS, KRISPY
♪ YOU'RE THE MAN" ♪
♪ IT'S ME AND DANIEL TOSH ♪
♪ AND WE'RE CHILLIN' IN L.A. ♪
♪ DOING PUSH-UPS
♪ AND GETTING GIRLS ALL DAY
♪ YEAH, WE'RE NEVER EVER ♪
♪ GOING BACK HOME
♪ 'CAUSE NOW ♪
♪ WE'RE BEST FRIENDS ♪
♪ AND WE'LL NEVER BE ALONE ♪
♪ I SAID IT'S ME ♪
♪ AND DANIEL TOSH
♪ AND WE'RE CHILLIN' IN L.A. ♪
♪ DOING PUSH-UPS
♪ AND GETTING GIRLS ALL DAY
♪ AND WE'RE NEVER EVER ♪
♪ GOING BACK HOME
♪ 'CAUSE NOW ♪
♪ WE'RE BEST FRIENDS ♪
♪ AND WE'LL NEVER BE ALONE ♪
♪ PEACE
♪